Today it's sumo suit ping pong!
That looked pretty easy
That was smooth
Looks like Otto's done that before
It wasn't that hard
No
You guys look hilarious
I might have this wrong way around
Yeah...
Otto you have it the wrong way around!
Otto looks like a sumo warrior
You both look like warriors
And guys
Don't forget to hit subscribe!
Emil run!
Almost
Come on Emil
You can do it
You can do it!
So close
Yes I got it
Is it hot inside the suit?
It's quite warm
Imagine how many sweaty people have been in that suit
I couldn't reach it!
It doesn't seem to be affecting Otto
Not much, no.
You got the full weight behind that smash
I didn't beat him in a ping pong match
but I can beat him in a sumo...
Okay, I lost both matches.
Whats your tactic?
I'm just going to crawl in
Okay see you
See you on the other side
I'm not sure why but
Miikka looks even funnier in the dress
It's just a...
Like a small round guy
I feel like my weight is doubled
Ah come on
Try
You can do it
Almost
There
No!
I'm not getting up for the second one
Now I'm stuck again
I think my shoelaces are undone
Miikka is more on the floor than he's
actually on his feet
I mean
He plays like normal
Thanks
It's funny to see the reactions from people
There is suddenly a guy with a sumo suit
Hello
Yes!
What's happening there?
It's like a...
Sleeping position!
It's quite comfortable actually
It's surprisingly comfortable!
Don't forget to hit subscribe
And watch our previous
episodes there!
Until next time!
Miikka you can come up already
Miikka?
Where did he go?